hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich mich heute ein video über meine
küchenmaschine über die kitchenaid isam
machen und farbe komme ich immer ganz
viele fragen von euch über facebook über
youtube aber auch über meinen job in
denen ich eigentlich immer wieder die
gleichen fragen über die küchenmaschine
gestellt bekommen
deswegen habe ich gedacht ich beantworte
ich zwar auch so immer ganz gerne aber
ich möchte einfach mal so ein
allgemeines video darüber machen und so
die häufigsten fragen in diesem video
klären die erste frage ist immer was es
so dass standardzubehör also die
kitchenaid wert der meisten im standard
zubehör geliefert das ist einmal die
küchenmaschine also die kids mit atis an
mit einer edelstahl schüssel mit dem
spritzschutz und mit den drei elementen
also mit dem flach hörer dem knethaken
und dem schneebesen und an dieser stelle
muss ich auch gleich mal denke ich
erklären wofür man eigentlich welches
früher element benutzt denn das ist
häufig somit fehlerquelle wo dann gesagt
wird mensch ich habe die butter die
kalte butter mit dem schneebesen gerührt
und irgendwie funktioniert es einfach
nicht deswegen denke ich sollte ich das
einfach kurz erklären den schneebesen
zum beispiel verwendet man immer dann
wenn man etwas flüssiges verarbeitet das
heißt wenn ich sahne schlagen möchte
oder wenn ich zb eiweiß steif schlagen
möchte oder einfach andere flüssige
zutaten den flach hörer nehme ich dann
immer wenn ich festere teilgehabt zum
beispiel in rührteig oder einfach auch
eine festere füllung wie zum beispiel
eine muss füllung für einen ustorf kann
ich ganz gut mit diesem flach hörer
verkneten
oder aber auch zum beispiel wenn ich
frikadellen machen möchte und ich möchte
diese hackfleisch mache masse nicht mit
den händen verkneten kann ich einfach
auch diesen flach hörer benutzen und
dann gibt es eben noch den knethaken den
knethaken verwendet wird dann wenig
feste teig gehabt wie zum beispiel
nudelteig oder brot und wenn ihr die
musik verwendet dann kann da auch gar
nichts passieren und eure teile und eure
massen wetten immer schön verrührt die
nächste frage ist immer wie wird die
küchenmaschine eingestellt also ihr
bekommt die geliefert und müsste
eigentlich gar nicht einstellen die ist
vom werker auf schon eingestellt
aber es kann natürlich passieren dass
beim transport sich hier diese schraube
verstellt und ihr dann die
küchenmaschine einstellen müsse wieso
müsst ihr sie einstellen es ist einfach
so wenn ich den hörer jetzt einsätze
dann musste er einfach die perfekte höhe
haben damit beim rühren
unten am topfboden nichts kleben bleibt
also nichts hängen bleibt denn bei der
kitchenaid ist es so die hatten
planetarische früher system und die
gewährleistet dass immer der komplette
zeigt also die ganzen zutaten immer
schön miteinander vermengt werden ohne
dass ich immer wieder mit den teig sein
muss und dass verrühren muss die
maschine schafft es komplett von alleine
und es geht eben nur wenn sie richtig
eingestellt ist das heißt dieser röhrer
darf weder zu hoch noch zu tief sein
wenn er nämlich zu hoch ist am sprit zum
beispiel die sahne oben raus und wenn er
eben auch zu hoch ist dann verrät er
eben die zutaten nicht richtig und ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach mal ganz
schnell wie man die maschine einstellen
kann und zwar steht es zwar auch im
handbuch drin da steht drin dass man das
mit dem flach hörer hier macht und es
muss einfach so eingestellt sein dass
der flacherer weder den schlüssel rand
noch den schlüssel boden berührt aber
wenn man jetzt die küchenmaschine ganz
neu zu hause hat und ein anfänger ist
und was ich einfach noch nicht auskennt
und auch nichts kaputt machen möchte
fragt man sich natürlich was ist jetzt
die optimale einstellung und dann kann
es zum beispiel auch passieren dass man
sie so einstellen dass der hörer einfach
zu hoch ist und dann rührt die maschine
eben nicht richtig immer ärgert sich
dann eben später drüber und im handbuch
wie gesagt stets drin mit dem flach
hörer ich allerdings habe den tipp
ich hab das nämlich auch so gelernt dass
man das einfach mit einem schneebesen
und einer münze macht weil dann hat man
es einfach anschaulich und man kann
direkt kontrollieren habe ich das
richtig eingestellt deswegen nehme ich
jetzt den schneebesen und den nehme ich
eben jetzt weil da einfach nichts
passieren kann also eine reine
vorsichtsmaßnahme weil ich jetzt gleich
mit einer münze arbeite ich lege zwar
hinten rein und hier oben habt ihr diese
schraube an der er dann die maschine
verstellen könnt rechts heißt der röhre
geht weiter runter links heißt der röhre
geht weiter hoch und ich möchte sitzt so
dass die münze von dem schneebesen nur
gelegentlich berührt wird gelegentlich
heißt so alle drei bis vier umdrehungen
und jetzt schalte ich einfach mal die
maschine einen stecker steckt schon und
höre mir das einfach mal kurz an
meine maschine sitzt fast richtig
eingestellt aber sie ist etwas zu tief
also der röhre
deswegen muss ich hier oben jetzt an der
schraube drehen und die schraube so ein
bisschen nach links drehen damit der
röhre ein kleines stückchen weiter nach
oben geht damit die münze von der von
dem schneebesen nicht berührt wird
gelegentlich ganz wichtig dabei ist dass
das center ist als es wurde auch schon
oft geschrieben ich habe es mit einem
euro versucht und es hat nicht
funktioniert das dürft ihr auf keinen
fall machen also es muss unbedingt eine
5 cent münze sein
und dann könnt ihr die richtige
einstellung eben noch
meine maschine ist es richtig
eingestellt ich höre die münzen nur
gelegentlich bzw der schneebesen berührt
sie nur gelegentlich und warum
vorsichtsmaßnahme normalerweise wie
gesagt wird es mit dem flachen
eingestellt aber ich hätte da jetzt
einfach ein bisschen angst dass die
münze den flach hörer diese
pulverbeschichtung beschädigen kann
deswegen nehme ich den schneebesen
eigentlich kann da nichts passieren
diesen sehr robust aber wenn ihr euch
einfach sicher sein wollt und vorsichtig
sein wollt dann nimmt einfach den
schneebesen zum einstellen
da kann dann auf keinen fall was
passieren
viele die sich die maschine kaufen
möchten fragen sich natürlich was sind
die unterschiede zwischen der kitchenaid
classic und zwischen der karte sind 4,8
liter natürlich erkennt er die
unterschiede erstmal nur hier am
schriftzug hier steht bei mir zum
beispiel arte sind mit drauf auf der
classic steht natürlich classic mit
drauf ansonsten könnt ihr auf den ersten
blick eigentlich gar keinen unterschied
erkennen denn beide maschinen sehen
gleich aus
die kitchenaid classic gibt es natürlich
nur in einer farbe in der farbe weiß und
die artus und gibt es aktuell den 28
farben und es werden eigentlich immer
mehr farben
was für mich ein großer unterschied ist
ist es standardzubehör da habe ich
nämlich hierbei der kitchenaid ates sind
diese edelstahl schüssel mit 4,8 litern
und dem griff und den spritzschutz und
bei der classic habe ich eine 4,3 liter
schlüssel ohne griff und ohne
spritzschutz und gerade küchenmaschinen
mit der schüssel mit griff finde ich
eben etwas praktischer weil wenn ich
jetzt zb man schweren teig darin
verarbeitet und die schüssel sich ein
bisschen verhakt das passiert immer mal
bei nudelteig zum beispiel kann ich den
griff benutzen einfach daran stoßen und
die schüsse leben schön lösen
das kann ich bei der schüssel ohne
griffe licht und deswegen finde ich
solche schüsseln immer ganz praktisch
ein weiterer unterschied ist die
wattzahl ich habe bei der kitchenaid
1300 watt und bei der classic 2 175 watt
ein weiterer unterschied ist die
standardausrüstung und zwar bekommt er
bei der tat ist immer ein kochbuch mit
dazu das ist das kitchenette kochbuch
und das in ganz viele tolle rezepte mit
dabei das hauptargument für mich ist
aber die garantiezeit ich habe bei der
kitchenette classic 2 jahre garantie und
bei der kitchenette artisten habe ich
fünf jahre garantie und ich finde fünf
jahre garantie im vergleich zu 2 jahren
ist schon eine menge
und deswegen ist es auf jeden fall den
preis dann auch wert die kitchenaid
classic ist das günstigste modell
die kids sind 4,8 liter wird weltweit am
meisten verkauft und auch hauptsächlich
nur von fachhändlern angeboten
und wenn noch mehr leistung möchte der
nimmt dann einfach die kitchenaid essen
mit 6,9 litern bei den anderen modellen
oder bei den anderen küchenmaschinen von
kitchenaid es ist auch so dass zum
beispiel bei diesem magnetic drei länder
da gibt es auch die classic variante die
hat zwei jahre garantie und es gibt die
artisten variante so wie ich sie habe
die als ganze sieben jahre garantie
und da merkt man einfach den
preisunterschied an der farbe und eben
an der garantiezeit und natürlich an der
leistung
aber bereits erklärt dass es unter den
modellen verschiedene preise gibt
zwischen der klassik der kitt schnitt
4,8 liter und der 6 9 liter aber es gibt
zb auch innerhalb der arten 4,8 liter
verschiedene preise und die haben
einfach verschiedene gründe
bei den metallic lackierungen ist der
herstellungsprozess etwas aufwendiger
und teurer
und deswegen sind auch die metallic
maschinen generell etwas teurer
ab januar wird übrigens die kitchenaid
in himbeereis 50 euro teurer weil dann
nämlich kitchenaid diese 50 euro an eine
brustkrebs stiftung spendet an die susan
komen stiftung und es ist an
deutschlandweit so momentan ist diese
preiserhöhung bei der pinkfarbenen geht
schnell zu und ab januar daneben bei der
himbeereis farben
ihr seht die farben spielen eine ganz
wichtige rolle und auch für mich war die
farbauswahl natürlich sehr wichtig als
ich mir damals die kitchenaid gekauft
habt heutzutage ist es ja auch nicht
mehr so dass man eine küche hat und die
küchentür verschließt und keiner kommt
in die küche rein
es ist oftmals so dass man eine offene
küche hat jeder kann reinschauen es ist
immer schön aufgeräumt und es ist
natürlich auch so dass die eltern auch
so ein schmuckstück in der küche ist ist
es bei mir auch deswegen habe ich mich
damals für die himbeereis farbene
kitchenaid entschieden und ich sehe es
auch bei mir habe ich habe ziemlich viel
bei mir zu hause in pink deswegen musste
die auf jeden fall in meiner einrichtung
reinpassen
ich habe es auch passen zu meinem
lippenstift ausgesucht damals auch wenn
ich den hut drauf habe aber es war halt
wirklich seine entscheidung
sie muss zu mir passen sie muss in
meiner küche passen und deswegen finde
ich es auch immer ganz toll dass man da
einfach diese große farbauswahl hat und
eigentlich ist da für jeden immer etwas
dabei
diese frage wird mir oft gestellt ob das
zubehör auch auf alle channel modell
passt ja das kitchenaid passt auch auf
alle kitchenaid modelle
die haben ja hier vorne diesen anschluss
wo man das eben weg schrauben kann und
zum beispiel die pasta walzen und auch
das andere zubehör hier vorne mit
anschließen kann
das finde ich ganz praktisch das hat man
zum beispiel bei anderen küchenmaschinen
nicht wenn jetzt zum beispiel gerade zur
günstige konkurrenten von der kitchenaid
in supermärkten oder in discountern
bekommt dann ist es oftmals so dass sie
eben dann nur eine küchenmaschine habt
mit einem standardzubehör so wie diese
hier zum beispiel und müsst euch dann
wenn ihr euch dazu entscheidet zum
beispiel im sommer möchte ich machen und
möchte den ice bereitet dazu kaufen kann
hier sehen bei der kitsch nicht einfach
mit dazu kaufen und habe mich noch extra
eine andere küchenmaschine in der küche
stehen sondern hat einfach das
zubehörteil bei dieser maschine western
jetzt so ich müsste jetzt noch mal extra
als bereiter kaufen und wenn ich
irgendwann passt da machen möchte dann
müsste ich mir noch eine pasta weise
kaufen und wenn ich irgendwann gemüse
noch klein schneiden möchte müsste ich
mir noch ein gemüse verteiler kaufen und
das ist bei der kitsch mit ebenso da
kann ich mir das zubehör immer nach und
nach mit dazu holen ich kann mich auf
weihnachten wünschen zum geburtstag
wünschen und kann einfach mit der
maschine mit wachsen
denn am anfang ist es vielleicht so da
möchte ich eher mal ein bisschen weniger
zu bereiten
und dann kommt man so ins kochen und
backen rein es macht immer mehr spaß und
dann möchte man auch immer mehr selber
machen und hat dann einfach die
möglichkeit immer aus zukunft
aufzurüsten und ich würde ich auch immer
empfehlen die kitchenaid immer direkt im
set zu kaufen da kommt nämlich viel
kostengünstiger weg als wenn ihr jetzt
sagt er holt euch ist nur dass standard
zu gehör und holt euch dann gewisse
sachen mit dazu also das ist so eine
empfehlung von mir
und ja bei der küchenmaschine ich meine
wenn ihr mal eine küchenmaschine findet
mit saugnäpfen dran wisst ihr es wird
einfach nur am material gespart am
gewicht gespart und deswegen wird sie am
besten die finger davon weg lassen
damit schnell zum beispiel nicht machen
green des weges an erste sportliche
auftritt macht es nicht leichter
natürlich hätte ich euch jetzt gerne
noch das ganze zubehör gezeigt
allerdings habe ich dafür einfach andere
videos abgedreht und euch auch in diesen
videos gezeigt wie man das zubehörteil
benutzt und wollte es aber getrennt ist
von diesem video machen und diese videos
findet ihr dann direkt in meinem shop
das habe ich jetzt auch so gemacht damit
ich einfach weniger fragen habe und ihr
einfach immer direkt wirst wie benutze
ich welches zubehör teile auf jeden fall
sollte man sich immer gut überlegen
bevor man sich eine küchenmaschine
anlegt ob man wirklich eine
küchenmaschine braucht denn ganz ehrlich
also wichtiger als eine küchenmaschine
zu hause sind eure zutaten dies sind
fürs kochen und backen wichtig für bei
mir zu hause sind wie maschinen
natürlich wichtig weil ich dadurch
extrem viel zeit und viel arbeit sparen
aber wie gesagt falls ihr euch an
anschaffen wollte sollte auf jeden fall
auf qualität setzen falls ihr
langfristig eben damit etwas anfangen
wollte jetzt komme ich noch zum
gewinnspiel ich habe er anfang des
jahres bei den philadelphia contest
mitgemacht und habe drei kitchenette
produkte gewonnen die ich an euch weiter
verlosen darf das große paket also die
kitchenaid arte sind mit 6,9 liter habe
ich bereits verlost und jetzt habe ich
hier noch den standmixer in rosa und das
kochbuch und diese zwei preise können
jetzt zwei meiner zuschauer gewinnen und
zwar könnt ihr mitmachen indem ihr einen
kommentar auf facebook instagram oder
auf youtube hinterlasst oder mein video
aufteilt und ich werde euch dann
nächsten mittwoch im video den gewinner
verkünden bzw die beiden gewinner und
ihr werdet mir dann eure adresse zu
senden und ich kann dann das päckchen an
euch losschicken
ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß
beim mitmachen und ganz viel glück und
wir sehen uns dann wieder beim nächsten
mal bis dahin tschüss